hey everybody Welcome to the very last
episode of Park attacked a taste of
Adventure and welcome to the very final
scenario in architect as a whole today
we are playing the moon and according to
the scenario description Humanity has
colonized the moon at last and that can
only mean one thing it's time to build a
theme park now we are in charge and we
need to do our best to entertain the
astronauts of tomorrow and the main goal
of this scenario is to have at least six
coasters in the park with an excitement
rating of 60 or above and then we have a
bunch of optional goals which we already
know we're not going to be able to reach
one small touch I just noticed about
this map is that the moon is made with
the in-game scenario editor or a Terrain
editor I should say so that's a nice
touch but
let's stop wasting time and actually
head into this scenario so
as we can see we have a very small plot
of land honestly why we get this small
plot of land when the moon is so big
anyway I'm not entirely sure maybe they
want to use the rest of the moon for
scientific purposes but something that's
also fun to point out is that all of the
guests in this map will have their own
little air bubbles helmets kind of thing
I don't know what the technology in the
future is like because otherwise they do
have normal clothes but you know who's
to say we don't get technology where we
just have to put this kind of helmet on
and we can keep the rest of our clothes
on maybe we've already terraformed part
of mars or uh the moon to some extent
anyway we start the scenario off with
one roller coaster with an excitement
rating of six a little bit higher even
90. so realistically we only have to
build five more coasters so that's not
too difficult the only kind of
challenging bit is that this coaster
does kind of fly through the middle of
the scenario so wow I am pretty happy
with how this layout turned out it is
definitely going to take a bit of work
to work around this thing and also we
don't have that much land available to
buy either so the coasters that we build
are really going to have to be quite
Compact and we're probably also going to
have to see how we're going to be able
to place multiple coasters in one area
have those things interact a little bit
and make this one a big fun place anyway
let's get started and let's start
building some stuff
all right now I'm going to do this video
in one big take and that goes for the
time lapse as well as my commentary
right now so hopefully by the end of
this my voice is doing fine or I haven't
gone off the supposed path for this
narration too many times because
honestly it's a little bit of a marathon
sometimes but in this case I just
couldn't stop building and by the time I
was done and ready to show off some
stuff
everything's basically finished so what
I wanted to start off with here is a
floorless coaster and in general the
focus of this episode is going to be on
The Coasters which is kind of different
from every other scenario I've done
usually the theming is definitely the
focus and while I do like to put time
into the layouts of The Coasters
it's kind of you know not the thing that
is the main attraction in the park even
though that doesn't really make sense
because usually you go to theme parks
for the roller coasters but you get what
I mean I think this is the first
scenario where I put more time into
doing the coaster layouts than I did the
scenery and I'm not even kidding there
there's a bunch of times where I
couldn't figure out what to do with
certain layouts or just had to test some
ideas when I wasn't even recording and
um eventually it took a lot of puzzling
to figure out where everything was going
to go and a big reason for that is that
I wanted to build some good fun layouts
with some creative elements of course
because that's a big part of the fun of
this game and of making a park but at
the same time I wanted all of these
coasters to interact with as many of the
other coasters as possible and that just
turned out to be quite a challenge
because we have to build five coasters
in total we need six coasters in the
Park but obviously one of The Coasters
is already here so the more coasters you
end up building the more you have to
work around the coasters that you've
already built and it gets to be a pretty
complicated task so um it's gonna get
interesting but for now I'm just
building the floorless coaster and the
layout is kind of similar in a sense to
the monorail coaster that's already
there just a simple out and back kind of
layout with a bunch of inversions
starting off with the lift Hill and then
kind of going out and back like that
with very typical b m floorless coaster
elements I would say and after the
corkscrew we have some interaction with
the terrain with an interesting
turnaround segment which honestly I'm
pretty happy with how that turned out it
looks pretty smooth and while I was
trying to figure out how to do this
other turnaround section here and it
took a little bit of try on error to get
a curve that looks smooth and also ends
up perfectly into this station while at
the same time keeping enough space
around to also add a break run so as you
can see I was kind of struggling on this
one and I went through a variety of
ideas even including whatever the heck
this was until I decided that you know
the original idea of just doing the
simple turn around very similar to the
first element was probably the the best
way to go forward so ended up just doing
that had to change the terrain a little
bit to make it fit but then you do get
that terrain conforming look that I
think really sells this layout and then
the second coaster which I started
building instantly after finishing the
first coaster is a gristlauer
eurofighter and as you can see this is
where things start getting a little bit
messy and where that kind of strange
interaction between coasters starts
playing a role and for this one I
decided to build the lift Hill right
above the lift Hill of the floorless
coaster
which works very well with the pieces
that we have in game because the
vertical drop and the vertical lift Hill
from the eurofighter leave two grit
spaces in between and those are just the
two great spaces that the floorless
coaster needs to do its lift Hill and
the return leg so um everything fits
pretty neatly together I'd say
at this point I also start thinking of a
color scheme besides being the main
attraction of this park the coasters are
also going to be most of the color I'm
going to leave the architecture very
simple and just keep to mostly gray
scales with maybe a few accents here and
there but the coasters are really the
main elements here and in fact I'm
building The Coasters first which is
something I normally do anyway because
you need to theme a little bit around
them but in this case the coasters are
really some of the main structures as
well so the buildings that I will be
building are kind of built around the
coasters and to enhance their layouts a
little bit as opposed to just being
buildings in this general area so it's
um it's gonna be something a little bit
different from my usual stuff now the
Euro Fighter layout is a pretty normal
eurofighter layout I would say we start
off with a vertical drop and then into
oh gosh I've practiced this thing into
an immelman there we go
honestly thanks for all the comments on
the last videos guys because
um I have a feeling that I'm finally
gonna be able to remember the difference
between an immelman and a dive Loop just
because uh with the dive Loop you dive
into the loop uh and in this case we
first have the half Loop and then we
have the twisty bit
um but yeah after that elements we have
this weird figure eight overbank section
uh which is not something that's very
typical for Euro Fighters but I feel
that in a very typical eurofighter
layout sense that this could very well
be a thing I think the only difference
between this and most typical layouts
for your Fighters is that this one's a
little bit larger and that's just
because it needs to fit over the lifter
of the already pretty hefty floorless
coaster
um so this is going to be the tallest
coaster and probably one of the most
intense ones
although it only has two inversions so
we have the first inversion and then a
very long drawn out inline twist
I say inline twist because ideally this
would be a barrel roll but because
architect likes
um the
uh the offset banking that we would need
to make barrel rolls I guess this would
typically uh classify as an inline twist
that said the definition between those
two elements and you know what exactly
it means to be a barrel roll or an
inline twist is kind of upward debate
generally a barrel roll has banking
offsets you know it's hardlined to where
your heart is so you rotate around your
heart whereas an inline twist it just
twists you normally an inline twist
would not be very comfortable on
coasters where you sit high above the
track and you could use them for example
on Wing coasters or something like that
where you sit on the side and it doesn't
really matter if it's not heart lined
but there are some cases where it's kind
of in between I think of blue fire in
the Europa Park where it's sort of a
barrel roll at least vertically because
you go up and down a little bit and you
go around your heart line like that but
at the same time
um on a horizontal plane I'm pretty sure
it doesn't really move that much so you
end up getting thrown around a bit and
honestly that's
probably the most fun role that I know
on any courses that I've been on but I'm
getting very off topic again this is
where it gets interesting in terms of
theming because this is the first
building and usually for architect
videos like these the first building is
always the building that kind of sets
the mood and the theme for the rest of
the park and in this case it's no
different this was kind of my testing
ground to see what kind of theme I
wanted to give this build and my
inspiration came from art deco I've been
saying that I've been wanting to do some
art deco scenery for way too long in
architect and I still haven't really
done it I think I've been saying it ever
since the uh the Mayan architecture
because obviously Art Deco is a little
bit inspired by uh Native American
architecture as well
um but yeah it's uh it takes some hints
from that some streamline modern and
stuff like that but at the same time
obviously we are on the moon so we have
to make it a little bit sci-fi but I
think Art Deco and sci-fi go very well
together uh especially because Art Deco
was kind of futuristic for its time so
we're really just uh going back to an
auto version of sci-fi in a sense which
I think is also why visual Fern style of
um Discovery Land in Disneyland Paris is
so good and why it continues to Ace to
age gracefully whereas the tomorrowlands
of Disneylands around the world are
looking more and more like an old Relic
from the past
um but that's a discussion for another
day also I'm just a really big fan of
arnuvo and Art Deco so
honestly whenever I can experiment a
little bit with things that are even
just a little bit inspired by it I think
it's always a good time
in this case we have those typical
vertical and horizontal details and
shapes that you typically find in
article the art deco architecture very
often it's quite simple in terms of
shapes and it's very reminiscent of
classical architecture but you really
have all these very streamlined details
and in this case the basic art pieces in
architect are so good for making art
deco buildings that it's a shame that I
haven't thought of doing this kind of
stuff earlier working with different
sizes and shapes of even just the cubes
allows you to do so much detailing in
that style speaking of which I decided
to use the pieces to do some path work
details as well here which is something
that I haven't tried much earlier either
but I think it's a it's a fun thing to
mess around with it's pretty easy to do
and as long as you only make the changes
in size between the different cubes so
0.01 so make it 100 of a few of a four
cube in the resize selector the
differences in sizes are super minimal
but you can overlap different cubes to
make different shapes and honestly these
are super simple shapes you could
probably do a lot more with this and
maybe even make some real paintings and
illustrations on your paths but in this
case I think you know with a very
geometrical style of the architecture
that I'm going for this is probably the
best way to add some color to uh
anything that's not a coaster and that
goes for the station of the coaster as
well because we have that pink sign
above it saying the name of the coaster
but that's really the only color in the
station building the rest of the
building is completely grayscaled
now here's an interesting bit where I
tried making a decoration for the tower
because the idea was always to make this
place over here some sort of Big Weenie
the centerpiece of the park and
incorporate The Coasters into the
theming elements but for a while I
wasn't really sure what to do exactly
I've already done something similar for
robo Park and even though I didn't have
all of these coasters going around in
the structure like I have for this one
um I still didn't want to build
something that was too similar to my
Robo Park build and that's when I had
the idea of
putting a sphere on top of this Tower
then I wanted to build and I'm gonna
tell you guys right away I'm not gonna
end up keeping this fear here I'm
honestly
still not sure if that was the right
decision but it just looks a little bit
weird I had the idea to make this sphere
in um a Minecraft sense where it's made
out of little cubes and I just used one
of those Minecraft
sphere generation tools and copied the
cubes from there so that was pretty
handy it was definitely a fun experiment
in trying to see if you could do
something like this in park Tech 10 how
hard it would be to do and honestly it's
not that hard to do
um but it just doesn't quite work it
felt a little bit off to put this on top
of a tower
um doesn't really match with the rest of
the tower structure in the near future
so I eventually decided to bend this
idea the reason that I still decided to
show you guys this
um or gals or everyone is because it's
going to be placed somewhere else and I
still thought it was an interesting
process to see this thing being made and
it looks pretty alright also at some
point I was experimenting with this
Unholy Abomination which I'm very glad I
didn't go with looking back at it now
um because I was looking at the sphere
and thinking you know it doesn't quite
look smooth enough maybe I should add
some extra spheres to it you know make
our sample size twice as large but it
ends up just looking even weirder
especially because I didn't do the
sphere place or I didn't do the block
placements perfectly to make an actual
sphere
um so it instead just ends up looking
like a weird crusty ball
um I'm not going with this look either
but for now I was content with it or at
least looking to finish the rest of the
structure so I decided to keep it for
now and see how I could build the
support structure
now building the support structure is
almost as difficult as making one of
these coaster layouts that go in and out
of each other because we have the
coaster the floorless coaster on on two
parts underneath this thing we have the
lift Hill for the Euro Fighter going
underneath it there's just too many
things to worry about clearance so I
eventually found out that if I put four
pillars on these Corners I could
perfectly support both the Euro Fighter
and avoid the floorless coaster from you
know cutting people's heads off
so I eventually figured this was uh the
best solution to go forward and I even
had some space in the Middle where I
could experiment with a funky uh
decoration support structure because uh
well I say that but I would also reckon
that this would add some structural
Integrity to the to the whole thing
because we do have those triangles
um reinforcing this whole structure so
it's probably a little bit stronger like
this but mostly it's a way to make this
Tower not look too boring and make it
seem like it really has some sort of
central look to it instead of just being
a ball on four stilts
um so yeah I'm decently happy with it
eventually I also added these pyramids
in the middle to once again add some
color just a little color accents and
give this thing some weights
um but that's basically it for the basic
support structure of this Tower I don't
have a name for this thing but you know
it could be anything honestly it's just
a random decoration where I'm not
entirely sure even what it is so at this
point I decided it's time to get rid of
the ball uh I blueprint I I made this
thing a blueprint because I also figured
I might be able to use this thing
somewhere else at some later stage I'm
not going to spoil yet what it is
exactly but I'm definitely going to save
it for a future reference otherwise
honestly I also wouldn't have shown you
guys uh me building the ball
and at this point I decided I already
have these squares underneath the
eurofighter that are supposedly
supporting the top of the structure I
might as well continue that theme and uh
once again do a kind of diagonal and a
straight Square to make a kind of Starry
look to this thing and the whole thing's
made out of basic shapes of course by
the way because those things are just
super handy uh and yeah that's basically
the structure it's uh it's all just
stuff that I came up with in the moment
so none of this is very planned and it
also does look a little bit like that I
suppose but after looking at this thing
for long enough and adjusting some of
the colors later on I'm pretty happy
with it
now at this point I was thinking I might
be able to use that sphere to make a
flat ride and give it an interesting
building but then I realized that the
size of the sphere uh would not allow me
to make a symmetrical Square over there
like it would be just half a tile offset
from the decoration on the Square and
that would just be horrible so I decided
not to go with that plan so instead for
a while I was thinking what if I put my
scrambled eggs over there on the hill
decided that nah that doesn't really
work out either So eventually I ended up
with this location where I can have this
Square be perfectly symmetrical at least
on this side and make an interesting
building to house the Twister now this
building is going to be one of the most
classically inspired buildings in the
whole build because I already have the
the Half Dome so I figured what if I
build basically a the sort of Roman
Temple sort of like the pantheon or like
a more Renaissance version something
like Saint Peter's Cathedral you know
the typical thing we have a classical
facade with some pillars and then a back
section with a dome you know that's a
it's a very typical building shape and
something you find a lot in classical
architecture it's very much copied it
all traces back to the pantheon in Rome
which by the way is one of my favorite
buildings ever and I'm getting slightly
off topic but that building is just so
cool
um it might be my favorite building in
the world honestly it's hard to pick a
favorite building in the world but just
the influence that that building has had
and being able to see it in real life
it's absolutely huge it was built by the
Romans over 2 000 years ago or maybe a
little bit less somewhere around that
time uh and it still looks amazing today
and just the influence in it it has had
on architecture in general around the
world world is
um very hard to describe
but yeah that's uh that's a story for
another day this building's a little bit
inspired by it except it has a little
bit of an art deco uh sci-fi uh sauce
all over it if you will
which is also fun to do because you can
stick to the basic shape that you
already know but give it very different
decorations and
um yeah it ends up looking like a
completely different thing while at the
same time I think the the inspiration is
somewhat visible in it
and once again the basic shapes to a lot
of the heavy lifting here so big shout
out to those shapes I feel like if
there's any learning curve that I can
see throughout my own Park Tech videos
there are so many things if I go back to
my old videos there are so many things
that I could point out like I used to do
those things differently and I've maybe
picked up on some different techniques
or ways to add more detail but I think
the power of these basic shapes is
something that I've probably learned the
most doing all of these scenarios I know
I barely used them in the beginning and
that was partly also because it's a lot
of effort to use them it's definitely
time consuming
but they are so powerful and especially
if you blueprint some pieces and reuse
them you don't have to spend too much
time doing details with them so honestly
those things are probably my favorite
decoration items in this whole game
now I'm uh kind of lagging behind the
time lapse at this point because here is
where I decided to add the fourth
coaster and at this point I was already
very confused as to where there was even
any space left to add another coaster
because I just wanted to give these
coasters as much interaction with each
other as possible
um but after a while of messing around
um off camera you know what YouTubers do
I figured out that this layout with a
stand-up coaster just managed to fit the
standard double Corkscrew and then some
twists in between the uh eurofighter
track so I ended up going with that
that's also the reason why I was able to
build the first half of this coaster
super quickly as you just saw and why I
struggled with the second half of this
coaster because I just wasn't really
sure how to return this thing back to
the station
not to mention this station is in kind
of a weird position because it's placed
right on top with this path over here
and I'm not sure if that's really the
most practical place to have a station
building
it also means that you know it's somehow
going to hide this path a little bit but
it was just too good of a layout not not
to place this thing here so I ended up
going with this anyway
and also at this point I decided to add
my staff room which is something that I
forget to do way too many times in my
playthroughs
um but at this point I'm already
swimming in money so decided let's just
place that thing down get that over with
funnily enough while I've placed the
staff room which I normally forgot I
didn't place any toilet buildings or
food buildings yet and if you're
watching this back you were maybe
already cringing at the fact that I was
forgetting to build them honestly I
wasn't completely forgetting about them
I just didn't do them yet and every time
I checked my Park statistics the park
was doing more than fine and I was
making more than enough money and all of
the guests were perfectly happy with the
state of things as they were so I didn't
really feel motivated to add any stars
and to be completely honest I'm not even
sure how this stuff would work I'm not
even sure how people are supposed to eat
with their astronaut helmets on I'm
pretty sure there's no way that they can
go to some kind of biosphere where they
can take their helmets off and there's
breathable uh Earth atmosphere with
oxygen and stuff at least that's nowhere
to be found in this park so I don't
think people would even practically be
able to eat and maybe something changed
in the stats of this scenario it could
be maybe they have adjusted for Moon
life in this scenario and make these
people less critical on uh some of their
uh bodily functions and whether I can
satisfy their needs or not in that
regard
um whatever the case may be I wasn't
really too concerned but of course I was
still very concerned about labor laws
and my work is unionizing against me you
know so I decided to build that staff
room and keep them at Bay for now
um and also I decided I wasn't really
happy with the building of the monorail
coaster that we start off with
but I do have to say you know I built
that building when I made this scenario
so nothing wrong with the building it's
not that I didn't like it uh it just
didn't fit into the style that I was
going for anymore so I had to give that
thing a slight makeover and I say slight
here because I did want to keep the
general shape and style of the building
around while at the same time making it
fit into this Art Deco aesthetic and all
of the colors and materials that I'm
using in the rest of the park
so I added all of these big cornices and
stuff using the basic pieces and are
decoized the uh that's not a word the
tower and to be honest this building
already did have some art deco energy so
honestly I don't think it's too much of
a stretch to even call the original
version Art Deco but now it fits into
the park a little bit more and speaking
of architecture I also decided to house
the station building of the stand-up
coaster in this Art Deco inspired kind
of building it's a little bit strange
but I think it works for the style and
it also works to provide a backdrop for
that huge immelman of the Euro Fighter
so I think that works Alright and then
for the station of the Euro Fighter I'm
going for something inspired by the
station of the floorless coaster namely
with very large Square cornices with
lots of detail on it
where again using different squares of
different sizes is perfect for this kind
of architecture you can first kind of
work out the general shape of a building
and the composition and then work on
some of the finer detailings and that's
always fun to do it was also at this
point that I was starting to realize
that all of my coasters were pretty
intense
and the stand-up coaster I reckon is the
most family friendly coaster but even
that it still has inversions it still
has that part in the tunnel which is
probably slightly scary and you're in
the stand-up position it's also a Togo
and a lot of people will hate ontogo for
being very rough coasters or at least
that is their
General assessment in the roller coaster
Enthusiast community
but to be honest I've only been on one
Togo stand-up coaster and that was
momonga standing Loop coaster in Tokyo
Japan and supposedly the Togo standups
in Japan are a lot more smooth than the
ones in the US
so that's probably where the
international bad rap comes from even
though there are some pretty good and
smooth examples of it to be found
unfortunately I believe momongo's
standing Loop coaster is nowhere no
longer with us
um so that's a shame although it is a
rare credit for me I suppose
um but yeah there are some good stand-up
coasters out there and let's just say I
hope that the stand-up coaster company
on the moon Colony also has their stuff
together and manages to make some smooth
decent coasters while we move on to the
next Coaster by the way which is the
hydraulically launched intermin coaster
now this would probably be considered an
intimate Blitz
I kind of wish we had LSM Launches on
this coaster type though because modern
LSM or modern intimate launch coasters
are typically LSM launched coasters they
did hydraulically launched coasters in
the early zeros for a while and there
are lots of good examples like storm
Runner and high speed in Italy and
countless more
um but their modern ones are all LSM
powered and I reckon they would do the
same on the moon they're also a bit
easier to use because with the LSM
launches you can also do a rolling
launch and I kind of wish I could do a
rolling launch on this coaster as well
maybe not the first launch but spoiler
alert I think it would be good to do it
on the second launch anyway I was trying
to figure out where this layout would go
and for the longest time I was making
this thing intertwined with the stand-up
coaster and the Euro Fighter as you can
see which looks super satisfying I love
that Tangled mess of track over there
um I just couldn't for the life of me
figure out where the coaster was going
to hat next it was just really difficult
to make it go down anywhere
um so I was seeing if I could go
underground over here and
I don't know it's right to end up in
some place it's all just try on air to
be honest
um but eventually I figured out that it
just wasn't really possible and also I
wanted to head into the other direction
and give this coaster some interaction
with some of the other coasters as well
um so I did a very similar elements as I
did on the first try of this layout just
the other way around
and now we end up on the other side next
to the stand-up coaster now something
that I wanted to keep in mind on this
layout that is pretty important on
launched coasters but that I don't see
that much talk about and that people
sometimes forget or don't realize which
is that if you build a launched coaster
the first element of your coaster should
be the tallest element and it should
work in such a way that if you clear
that element the train should be able to
clear the rest of the layouts because
the last thing you want is to get a
train stuck in the middle of the layout
and have to tow it out to some other
place so normally with the case with
launch coasters
you can often have that a launch might
not really work correctly or something
goes slightly wrong so the launch speed
is a little bit less and in cases like
that you just want to prevent the
terrain from ending up in the middle of
the layout and you want it to smoothly
roll back into the launch pad and maybe
even launch again and have a proper
reroll which is something that coaster
enthusiasts are always after so you
might even be able to please some people
with that but yeah that's always
something something to keep in mind and
that also made working out this layouts
a little bit harder but in this case we
have that first element where it first
goes up a little bit and then it goes up
a little bit more so I think this works
for uh the first element rule sometimes
you see launch coasters especially
nowadays also take some liberties with
the concepts and try to work a small
element into the layout before you hit
the big element so for example you might
hit a small airtime pop before you go
into the top hat that follows the launch
but even in cases like that the airtime
pop will be followed by a leveling off
of the track and not just by a a part of
it going down because then you could
still get stuck in the valley in between
so yeah that's just some uh some launch
coaster theory for you at the same time
I'm trying to head my way back into the
launch section because I want to do a
second launch and I wanted to keep this
launch very close to the first launch
and kind of do that cheeky Terran bits
where you can see the other coaster
launching and you have just one trench
that everything launches through
um because it just looks super
satisfying and in this case it also
gives you some more interaction with the
terrain with the paths with the other
coaster it's just a good time all around
which is also good in an in-game sense
because Park attacks rewards you with
extra excitement value if your coaster
does some interaction Shenanigans with a
scenery or with terrain which is
something that Roller Coaster Tycoon
always did as well and
honestly I think some of the coasters in
this map have some of the highest
excitement values than I've ever had in
any of my Parks but I'll show that off
at the end of this video that's uh
something to worry about later for now I
wanted to figure out how to make the
second half of this layout and
honestly because this layout is so long
and has two launches and two completely
different sections it really reminds me
of modern intimate Blitz coasters which
is not the official name that intimate
uses but I'm gonna use it anyway because
it's a great name
um something like
um what's it called again steel dolphin
I believe in China uh or Cheetah Hunt
something like that it's very well
reminiscent of stuff like that as well
where you have a layout with two
launches
um with lots of air time and interesting
elements kind of out and back as well it
really takes you throughout the whole
park and I think it's just a good time
the only thing this coaster doesn't have
is an inversion but I think that's also
good for at least having some variety in
the coaster selection in this park
because if it weren't for that then
every coaster in this park had
inversions and although we still don't
have a family friendly coaster I think
it's good enough to have some variety in
Coaster types and what their layouts do
also there's a pretty good reason why
there's not a family-friendly coaster
and that is that a family friendly
coaster most likely wouldn't have the
minimum excitement rating that I need to
finish this scenario so there's that as
well
now finally the sixth coaster of this
scenario and yes we are finally getting
there uh is going to be an intimate what
am I saying it's going to be in a b m
Wing Rider Wing coaster it's a wing
coaster sometimes I still say Wing Rider
because that's the odd name that it's
been used to use doesn't matter it's a
bean and Wing coaster and it's a little
bit inspired I would say by the b m Wing
coaster coming to Legoland Deutschland
and it's funny because every now and
then there will be a coaster announced
and built somewhere in the world that
just takes the coaster game World by
storm and I feel like recently that
little wing Rider
I say it again that little wing coaster
was that coaster and I think it's
because it's just such a weird unique
quirky little coaster
um so for anyone who doesn't know
Legoland are obviously very children and
family oriented theme parks uh owned and
operated by The Lego company and
typically while they do have some roller
coasters they are always family coasters
and recently the Legoland in Germany
announced and started building a b m
Wing coaster but it's absolutely tiny
it's a it's a family Wing coaster and
while it does have inversions uh it
doesn't really reach very tall Heights I
believe it's only something like nine
meters tall it's very slow and graceful
and probably quite smooth
um and it's just it's a coaster type
that we've seen before but it's a
concept that we've never seen before
there's only one other b m coaster that
sometimes a family coaster which is the
b m inverts when for some reason one of
the Happy Valley Parks in China I
believe it was decided to build a b m
inverts but give it the layout of
overcome a family invert
why they went to b m for that is still a
mystery to me
um but yeah it's it's not completely
unheard of to have a b m uh family
coaster but a b m Wing coaster with such
a small and family oriented layout is
definitely something new so I was
inspired by that to build this pretty
small wing coaster although it's still
quite sizable and it does have that loop
at the end which is a sunken very deep
into the ground I still think this is
the most family-friendly coaster in the
park and if Legoland can build a family
Wing coaster wind inversions then so can
I and
um yeah it should be pretty mild and not
too intense compared to especially some
of the other elements in this park plus
it was a fun uh experiment to try and
see if I could take the station building
that was already there for the monorail
coaster and that I already reworked into
the kind of art deco style and see if I
could also attach another part of a
station building to it and essentially
use one building for two stations and I
think it's a success it's actually one
of my favorite parts of this whole build
and that's just the fun of this in
general because it took a lot of effort
to try and see how I could mix all of
these coasters together and we end up
with some spaces that are very cluttered
and with lots of scenery and coasters or
ending up with one big garbled mess of
track at the same time that's really the
fun of it and these are some of the most
fun spots to just look and see The
Coasters go around and especially to see
The Coasters also have some interaction
as you just saw the wind coaster and the
monorail coaster were just interacting
around that turn around and maybe it's
just me as a theme park nerd using the
word interaction like this to describe
two rides coming very close together and
running at the same time and being able
to wave to the people on the other
terrain but that stuff
ah that really gets me going that's
fantastic even this sitting in a car and
I'm this is this is this is also a
strange way to go off topic but even
even sitting in a car on a highway
driving and uh Crossing underneath uh
rail tracks and then uh going underneath
that bridge right as a train is is
crossing is just absolutely fantastic uh
that's the kind of interaction I live
for and I think everybody at least every
Dutch person who's ever been in a car
and
um
on the what is it the a16 I'm not
entirely sure or the a44 anyway that one
Highway that goes right underneath the
main airport of the Netherlands because
uh they have that spot where you can
actually drive uh underneath one of
their runways when a plane is uh going
over it which is
oh just absolutely glorious and it's
those little moments that I want to
recreate in my theme parks
um that sounds weirdly sentimental and
specific but it's just that feeling that
you know I'm going for and I think if
there's any way to get that feeling it's
probably to intertwine a bunch of
different coasters all around each other
give them all as many block breaks and
trains as possible or at least as
reasonable and you're bound to have a
bunch of interaction and just watching
this park and seeing all of the trains
uh go around here it just adds so much
kinetic energy and it's really fun to
see
now here is where I started getting a
little bit experimental with the scenery
uh honestly I'm not really sure what
this is but I've been very slightly
annoyed that I can't add any foliage to
this Park which is also natural you know
it's the moon there aren't going to be
any trees here but normally foliage is
that kind of clutter between buildings A
way to fill up the space and to blend
everything together a little bit there's
just something about having a building
and then putting a tree next to it and
some bushes and that kind of makes it
blend into its environment a little bit
more as opposed to just being plopped
down and kind of standing out a little
bit and it's that feeling that I was
missing from this map because I couldn't
put any foliage in so at some point I
made these weird structures that kind of
seem like something's crystallizing
outward from the pathways and the
buildings uh or maybe some wiring or
stuff like that still not entirely sure
what it is but it looks pretty cool I
think I'm pretty happy with it uh so I
decided to keep it around and it's
partly made using cornices and partly
made using
um the art shapes of course but also
partly using some cables so there's
definitely some mechanical stuff going
on there as well
but I like the way that it Blends
everything together a little bit more
and doesn't make the paths feel just as
out of place as they were especially
with the big barriers acting as fences
and overall the scenery in this map is
super similar you can already kind of
see it uh you know it's it's kind of
blending together because it's also
similar but I think it works to keep it
that simple because the focus is really
on the coaster track and the coaster
tracks are what add the color into this
map
now moving on the last part of this map
that's that needs its scenery is the
section over here with the intimate
launch coaster and I figured this would
be a great place to put my final path
artwork and this one's once again a
little bit different than the other ones
I would also say this square is a little
bit smaller
um so I think it works you know we have
three squares slightly different shape
and size and a slightly different
decoration in the middle but at the same
time they're all pretty much the same
now the station for this coaster is
probably the most basic shape heavy
building that I've done so far in the
middle we have this large diagonal the
cube shape that goes alongside the
entire length of the building and then
on the sides of that we have the roof
for the the main station part jutting
out which is a very sci-fi-ish shape but
once again it's that kind of thing where
it it isn't too hard to pull off
honestly I think it looks slightly more
uh difficult than it really is a lot of
it comes down to just making one of
these diamond shapes and then copying it
around and then a lot of it can just be
filled in with basic shapes so it's
mostly just a little bit time consuming
but once you get the hang of it I feel
like it becomes easier to do as well
especially with
um you know a decent knowledge of what
size you can make your pieces and that's
all dependent on the grid and pretty
simple as well so for example for this
build the major white pieces so the
major white cubes are all
0.25 size so that's exactly a quarter
Cube if a whole cube is you know one by
one by one on a grid space
um
so you just have to press alt for to get
the quarter grid and as you as long as
you put all of the pieces on the grid
they're all perfectly aligned and that's
just what makes working with these
pieces uh so satisfying and so easy and
then whenever I use these smaller cubes
I usually go for a point 13 size which
means that you have to work on the 8th
grid which is also pretty easy to do
just odds and then eight and you're on
that grid and you can perfectly fill
that also make the quarter cubes using
those 8th grid pieces and using those uh
those eighth cubes as well if you for
example want only a half of a quarter
Cube you can make it out four of these
eight pieces this stuff is just
infinitely uh applicable to so many
different things and the same goes also
for decorations if you want to put a
decoration on one of those cubes just
take a cube and make it a little bit
larger and it'll stick out which is what
I ended up doing to create these
decorations on the side of this diagonal
roof line here
so
um yeah definitely something that
throughout my architect career if you
will I could have made more use of and
I've only been able to start discovering
right at the end of this uh scenario
play through let's play series which by
the way I haven't really talked about
this much but this is going to be the
last episode of this series honestly I'm
going to miss this
um I'm kind of sad that I don't have
another scenario to go to after this
it's taken years to go through all of
the scenarios and sometimes it's taken
me a lot of time to finish one scenario
sometimes I've been burnt out for a
while on this but every episode has been
fun to make and I'm going to miss it
definitely
um and I realized that most of these
scenarios I've made myself and if I
really wanted to maybe I could make more
scenarios and then play them but
honestly that feels a little bit lame if
they're not part of the game
um so to answer all of the questions
that are probably going to come up and
that I've already seen in some of my
comment sections earlier I'm not going
to continue these scenario playthroughs
or at least I'm out of scenarios to do
in the game and I'm not going to take
the astrotron approach and go back into
these scenarios and maybe do them even
better this time around
um what I might do but this is only for
a few scenarios
um
and I'm still not sure if I really want
to give this a shot but what I might do
is play a few of the scenarios on the
workshop especially because some people
have been making great scenarios in this
game astrotron is one of them and I
think that deserves a shout out as well
but most likely
I'm going to make a Sandbox park at some
point in future or work on
um dioramas and Miniatures which is
something that I'm honestly gravitating
toward more because it doesn't take that
much work and every diorama could be one
episode for example plus there are
monthly diorama contests in park Tech
which so far I never participated in
because I really don't have the time for
it but if this series is done maybe I
have the time to do a diorama every now
and then and I think this game is
perfect for those things as well because
you can make the park map as small as
you want and then you just have another
small square or rectangle floating in
space that you can build your diorama on
and it's really fun it's a small
bite-sized opportunity to work out a
theme or or make a small coaster layout
and then you don't have to worry about
it too much more maybe I'll also use
some mods but honestly at this point
it's all just speculation because to
tell you the truth I'm just going to end
up doing whatever I want to do and I
think these videos just end up the best
videos if I'm actually doing stuff that
I like as well so
I'm not going to do any promises just
know that these are the ideas that I'm
playing with in my head and then I'm
very far from done with Park detect
because it's just a really fun game
now to get back into this park Tech
episode for a little bit
um I just finished the station of the
launch coaster of course with a little
decoration in front of it and at that
little roof to the q line building of
the Florida's coaster because that was
sorely lacking this whole time I just
couldn't really come up with an idea for
how to theme that thing and finally the
last thing that I had to work on is a
food court at last finally the people
can eat
um but yeah I'm not really sure how how
the people are going to eat this again
but I felt really bad if I didn't
include this at least because you know
it's a very basic amenity every single
Park that I've built I believe had this
uh and it's a little bit strange to
build the food court lasts but I think
it's the perfect way to round up this
part of the park uh add one more
building to this square and
um give the people what their they're
probably needing at this point
um but again not really sure why people
aren't asking for it much more
they did at one point but that was
because the exit path of the Flawless
coaster was uh or no of the of the wing
coaster was broken so people got stuck
there so obviously that tanked my
ratings for a bit maybe you noticed I
didn't really call attention to it at
the time but that did happen at some
point
um but yeah that's going to be it for
this episode so um let's have a quick
look in real time and see how this whole
thing turned out because unfortunately
in the middle of the time lapse I also
succeeded in all of the goals because I
already finished the wing coaster even
though it was testing so I already
reached the goal so unfortunately
there's no live confetti this time
around but I definitely want to take you
guys on a tour
all right so here's what the park looks
like at the end of this playthrough very
different from any of the parks that
I've built so far in any other scenario
and I think the lack of foliage is a big
part of the reason for that
um but also uh let's just do some povs
of the coasters because that's what
we're here for anyway and let's start
off with the Voyager I'm just going to
do these chronologically I think you
might notice with this layout that this
layout was made before any of the other
coasters were there or before I even
decided to make all of The Coasters
intertwined in the first place so this
one has a pretty free-flowing even
standard I would say b m floorless
layout it definitely doesn't have the
the total standard layout or anything
because it it does have an unusual order
of elements I suppose and it is terrain
conforming but all things considered I
could very easily see b m built
something like this IRL
and it's also interesting how everything
kind of took shape from there with uh
the construction of the lift Hill of
Gemini here uh which is I suppose where
the madness really started I think it
was only when I started building this
lift Hill over the Florida's coaster
that I reckoned hey I could actually do
something crazy with this stuff uh so
yeah here's Gemini the gerslauer Euro
Fighter I haven't really talked about
the names for The Coasters much because
I don't always name my coasters in these
scenarios but if at this point you can
already start seeing the trend for the
names of these coasters uh go ahead and
take a guess why these ghosters are
named the way that they are
anyway Gemini is the tallest and fastest
goes through on this entire scenario and
I think
uh it's it's one of my favorites yeah
it's just a really short but big
eurofighter layout and it's definitely
something that I could see girls Lauer
doing in real life but most of all it's
just that interaction with especially
the Flawless coaster where it works out
really well and where everything really
starts to
be one big mess of roller coaster Trek
next we have
um I believe if I remember correctly
Orion
let's see oh well one of the trains is
still in the station so I guess that
leaves us some time to look at the
station building itself uh this was also
inspired by a real-life Art Deco
building uh go ahead and guess if you
can see where the inspiration came from
uh although it is pretty different I
think the art deco is pretty
recognizable in this case whereas the
station of the Euro Fighter is really
just
a riff on the station of the Voyager
um and this layout kind of surprised me
with how simple it is at the start just
two corkscrews and some Meandering but I
think that's fine for a stand-up coaster
really the layout should be a little bit
more simple it does some funky s-band
stuff while it's in the tunnel
um
but what I'm really happy with with
these coasters in general is that I
didn't end up with layouts that look
like they're shoe horned in in a sense
that go through all of these weird turns
and elements just to be able to interact
with each other but generally I wanted
all of The Coasters to have a layout
that at least makes sense
um speaking of which let's take a look
at the launch coaster X15 here
uh and this one is very obviously an
intimate Blitz inspired coaster a little
bit like Taran especially with the two
launches side by side
um and of course a layout that's filled
with just lots of twists and turns and
really not particularly focused on
inversions or air time although it does
have one here
um I was trying to get these launches to
hook up to each other to be synchronized
unfortunately I couldn't really get that
to work with block break timing or stuff
like that and I still wanted this thing
to be as efficient in terms of
throughput as possible also
what are you doing
okay I guess that can happen sometimes
uh let's just let's take a look in the
meantime while these people are stuck
here
um but yeah
I was hoping but unfortunately that's
just not possible in the game to make
this an Lim launch coaster just like
Taryn is in real life so we wouldn't
have to stop in the middle of the layout
but the way that it is in the game is
that we have to do two hydraulic
launches I guess realistically speaking
if we compare it to a real life
experience it's not that much of a
drawback because honestly if you ask me
hydraulic launches are better than Lim
launches or LSM launches they just have
a bit more of a kick to it and
especially when it comes to intimate
hydraulic launches like you see on Rita
or desert racer or any of the strata
coasters those things uh have a real
kick but at the same time honestly
terran's second launch even though it is
an LSM launch is one of my favorite
launches in the world because it's right
in the middle of that tunnel and the
sensor speed is absolutely insane not to
mention the sound that it makes is it
obvious that I'm watching for time here
because I'm waiting for that mechanic to
come but where the heck is it uh oh it's
being worked on okay so we should be
good to go soon I suppose Let's uh let's
quickly fast forward for a little bit
I honestly how long is this okay there
we go there we go there we go okay okay
so now the second train comes and then
just before that launches we should be
good to go yeah there we go cool
uh so yeah second part of the layout and
as always it's important to remember
with these kinds of coasters to have the
tallest element right after the lift
Hill uh so you can make sure that you
can make the rest of the layout as well
uh which again is just some turns and
stuff and then we're back into the
station and this is one of those
stations that looks pretty simple and I
guess that goes for most of the
buildings in this scenario but still
took a lot of time because it's
completely made out of those basic art
shapes but at the same time I kind of
like it because all of these buildings
are very different from buildings that
I've done in playthroughs in other
scenarios so far
um and it definitely taught me a thing
or two about how to use these basic
shapes and how you can get and get some
pretty creative shapes and decorations
using them so it's it's something that I
might take with me for future Park
attack builds
speaking of which this is the very last
episode of the park attacked campaign
playthrough because we're out of
campaigns uh it's as easy as that
um and I'm kind of kind of bummed out
about it because this has been so much
fun to do I know it's taken me a couple
of years uh sometimes just because it's
very time consuming to do these scenario
playthroughs uh but when I started doing
these I wasn't sure if I was going to do
the whole game honestly um
but as soon as I did a couple of them I
realized that while these videos are
very time consuming to make and they're
very long as well I think this one is
gonna go over an hour as well
um they're just so much fun to do and
the combination of gameplay and
decorations and trying to find a balance
between that because this isn't all
about just the decorations this is
definitely partly about the challenge of
making these uh of actually finishing
these scenarios according to their
challenges as well and that's just been
a lot of fun and it's really taken me
back to the days of Roller Coaster
Tycoon still my all-time favorite game
um but at the same time a bit more
updated and with much more decoration
and creativity but also in terms of the
layouts this coaster Builder is just so
much fun because it's really easy you
can put down a layout in 10 or 15
minutes but at the same time there's so
much flexibility with it
um so yeah I've really enjoyed this
series I've I hope you guys have and as
for the future of architect I'm still
not entirely sure but I definitely don't
want to leave this game forever so
there's gonna be some stuff in the
future unfortunately with the with the
nature of my channel there are just so
many games that I'm interested in and
there's so little time to actually do
stuff with them uh considering real life
responsibilities as well uh but you guys
have definitely not seen the last of
Arctic and whether it'll be custom
scenarios or some kind of sandbox or
dioramas still thinking about that one
but I'll definitely be back so all in
all thank you guys so much for watching
this video and thank you guys so much
for watching this whole series all of
your comments and help and tips and
everything are super appreciated you
guys make this much more fun to me to do
for me than just doing it on my own so
uh yeah also I'm I'm very happy to see
all of your responses to playing these
scenarios yourself as well having made a
bunch of them it's really interesting to
see people play them and see the amazing
kind of stuff that the architect
Community does with these games
especially on some of the um Community
challenges with dioramas and stuff like
that so gonna gonna stay in touch with
everyone for sure
um but this is it I'm really gonna have
to cut this series off here man it feels
weird to do that anyway once again thank
you guys for everything and I'll see you
in the next one bye-bye